à quel genre de personnes avons-nous affaire
ici un ensemble de perps avec des compétences très inhabituelles
Utah J'ai besoin d'une théorie alors pourquoi ne pas déployer
votre parachute au-dessus de la jungle et vous échapper
comme une personne normale parce que je
pense que ce sont des gens normaux monsieur le
peuple  derrière ces vols, il y a
des athlètes extrêmes qui utilisent leurs compétences pour
perturber le marché financier international
,
ils se fichent de savoir qui est tué dans le
processus, ils m'appellent Bodhi,
il y a quelques milliards de dollars d'
or là-bas qui vont le voler, non, nous allons le
libérer  tu me montres exciter ton cerveau
ce sont des enfants qui font la fête dans leur vie nous
pouvons avoir ces gars j'ai juste besoin de plus de temps
la seule loi Tomatis est la gravité